I'm in Toronto Canada and Toronto is
cold for love the years good winter
boots are a necessity they've got to be
warm they've got to be waterproof but
also they're going up so great backs
when you suddenly walk on a patch of ice
this is winter laughs and it's part of
the challenge here environment
assessment laboratories and the Toronto
Rehabilitation instituting this it's
their tilting frozen floor if you want
to find out whether people are at risk
at risk of falling at risk of a road
accident at risk of something you need
to put them in a challenging environment
and see how they respond what we have is
four modules for different things we
have the world's actually most realistic
driving simulator now when it rains in
our simulator it actually rains we also
have steer lap where we have people walk
up and down stairs and we suddenly and
unexpectedly move the room and they have
to grab the handrails and we can see how
effective the handrails are or the stair
design 21,000 people in Ontario every
winter
on average end up in our emergency rooms
because they fall on an ice and snow so
the purpose of winter lab is so that we
can do two things one is that we can
test the boots and inform consumers what
they should buy and the other is we can
help companies and ourselves develop
better boots terrifying it's an ice box
really it's insulated we can generate
winds we can actually make nice white
fluffy snow we can control the air
temperature very precisely and we can
control the temperature of the ice very
precisely we actually have a group of
graduate students like every other
University lab you've ever been to
because they're not very expensive and
they're sort of disposable who do this
testing and because we want sort of
uniformity to get honest very good us
now in order to test the performance of
shoes we choose to put winter lab on top
of a platform that we can gradually tip
it just feel what gravity is shifting we
tip it as you walk up and down until the
moment that you use
slip we have a an angle which we think
is just acceptable it's seven degrees we
actually take the minimum value of
several people if you can make seven
degrees up and down confidently we give
you one snowflake this is a good shoe
okay yeah
now I can literally just walk normally
at the moment we've got a scale of three
snowflakes and that was because the
first time we ever did this 90 out of a
hundred boots failed to get one
snowflake and nothing got better than
one snowflake so to publish it as a five
snowflakes scale looked a bit depressing
we've already tested some prototypes for
next year and they're getting two and
three snowflakes the last one I put my
foot down it just stays where it is we
are really quite confident that
eventually we're going to be able to add
some more snowflakes at the four and
five level it raises another interesting
point and that is can you have too much
friction we're a long way off that yet
but of course more than half the Falls
that you experience are people tripping
up we will eventually decide whether a
five snowflake shoe is a good idea or
not
I'm really happy in two years we've done
two things one is that we've changed the
buying habits of people and the other is
now the industry is improving the
quality of boots and we're helping them
do that thank you very much to all the
team winter lab here at the Toronto
Rehabilitation Institute pull down the
links in the description for more about
them and their research I swear I'm not
deliberately trying to do that
yep